you're watching this amber hurt and uh  johnny depp what a sweetheart of a girl  she is right just listen to it the more  i watch her like they showed a recording  yesterday  of how she's like you know the attorney  says do you know why johnny doesn't look  at your eyes and he's like no  do you look at johnny's eyes in court i  do does he look at you no do you know  why i don't know you should know i don't  know then she plays the recording  and it's a recording of johnny and amber  and she's like please stop touching me  he's like come on please i just want it  one more time i want to hug you because  i i know i'm so ugly i was like stop  touching me it says  you will never  see these eyes look at you ever again  never you hear in the recording  johnny got to a point that i will never  can you imagine a loved one telling you  i will never make eye contact because  you know love the eye contact i will  never look at you ever again right he's